et si républicains pour appâter ma
gueule aujourd'hui peintre emmanuel
patron c'est une oeuvre je dirais même
les râles parce que payez d'abîmer le
pays décliner le pays ne pourra pas
supporter cinq ans supplémentaires
d'inaction ou d'erreurs d'absence de
réformes qu'il faut battre emmanuel
macron et seul un candidat des
républicains pour rabattre emmanuel
babeau donc nous avons une
responsabilité
cette responsabilité elle impose des
devoirs et parmi ses devoirs il y à
l'unité le rassemblement et je crois au
tour du petit déjeuner grâce à christian
d'être pauvre est bien est apparu avec
force de façon unanime la volonté
commune de porter cet esprit d'unité de
rassemblement les quatre ans a dit que
si je gagnais balle congrès emmanuel
badu serait réélu est ce que ça c'est
pas une petite phrase qui veut dire
je crois plus celui ou celle qui gagnera
le congrès aura de la force pour battre
et manuellement voilà chacun aura ses
arguments chacun de campagne
c'est aussi le temps de la campagne qui
s'ouvre une campagne sur les idées sur
le fond chacun a sa méthode chacun a sa
personnalité moi je considère qu'il faut
couper le robinet d'eau tiède on ne peut
pas dire simplement qu'on va faire
mieux on plus les manuels m'apprendre je
crois qu il
ont la responsabilité en tout cas ça
sera mon attitude dans cette campagne de
dire on va radicalement changer moi je
porte un projet de profondes ruptures
avec un positionnement très clairement à
droite avec une ligne intangible et
danse
refuser toutes sortes d'alliances
avec
et sa santé j'aimais différence je suis
le seul
l'ida ne pas avoir voté manuellement
secundo je le dirige la france
des blancs en 2017
doi tirano à nos électeurs très
clairement ça fait partie des
différences qu'on peut avoir mais ces
différences elle n'empêche pas le moment
au volume l'indispensable rassemblement
merci beaucoup
beaucoup
tu es
[Musique]